so wir kommen dann zum nächsten
leserfoto und zwar jürgen ruland hat
sich am bild kämpft gewandt und uns
geschrieben
das kann doch gar nicht sein ein
reiseveranstalter hat die für april 2020
gebuchte reise einfach so auf april 2021
verlegt kam uns auch ganz komisch voran
kempkens konnte sich das auch gar nicht
erklären
und jetzt haben wir ihnen aber noch mal
hier in der leitung hallo jungen ruland
ist er noch danke sie haben probleme mit
trennt uns gehabt wie lief das ab 276
dass ich bin halt da bin ich so nie mein
freund mir nach dem buch und die soll
das sechserfeld beginnen
dass das nicht geht es war mir schon
klar habe ich das ist daher nicht am 31
dritten bekamen wir eine mitteilen und
gleichzeitig aber auch nicht bestätigt
werden 2021 mit dem hinweis dass die
gleiche zahl bereits umgebucht sein
da frage ich mich dazu kontaktiert
wollten ja nicht einfach weiß nicht ob
ich das überhaupt oder grenzen das ist
jetzt wird das noch erlebt nächstes jahr
also ich bin sicher wir leben das wir
haben uns natürlich sofort schlau
gemacht hatte ich noch hier in der
sendung versprochen und ich habe auch
trennt uns angefragt das kann ja wohl
auch nicht sein
und tatsächlich hier ist hier ist der
beweis hier ist das schreiben von trend
urs da sieht man es auch und die
schreiben in der sache ruland sie geben
zu das war tatsächlich eine unglückliche
kommunikation
aber diese eigenwillige verlegung
entspricht dem aktuellen wunsch der
mehrheit unserer kunden können sie sich
das vorstellen herr roland alle wollen
das automatisch alles verlegt wird also
in einem deutschen ein fechter ist dass
ich mir keinen vertragen
ich bin immer noch groß geworden
verträge sind einzuhalten
das habe ich ja einfach eine grundschule
glane
ja und aber immerhin die gute nachricht
schreibt der geschäftsführer von trend
wird herr daldrup wenn er ruhland und
seine lebensgefährtin diese neuen termin
nicht möchten dann leisten wir natürlich
rückerstattung also bild kämpft war hier
erfolgreich haben sie schon irgendwas
von trendhouse gehört und das direkt
noch nicht sagen genau und darüber
freuen sie sich auch jetzt müssen sie
keine mails mehr schreiben und müssen
nicht auf facebook irgendwas schreiben
sondern wir haben hier den fall für sie
geklärt zufrieden
danke danke an kempkens konnte damals
den fall auch nicht fassen einfach zu
den reisetermin verlegt ist das einzige
dann was man machen kann sich noch an
die bildseite zu wenden
na ja und das ist zumindest eine
möglichkeit druck zu machen
und natürlich sieht man hier das ist
ganz das ist wirklich gut gelöst werden
konnte aber wir sehen im moment genau
dieses problem
die veranstalter versuchen zeit zu
gewinnen genauso wie der reisende jetzt
auch zeit gewinnen sollte und weitere
vorauszahlung zurückhalten sollte sollte
man versuchen das eben die veranstalter
die wollen eben nicht zurückzahlen weil
sie immer noch irgendwie gehofft haben
dass dieses gutschein system vielleicht
kommt aber das scheint ja jetzt per
sonntag irgendwie vom tisch zu sein
und jetzt müssen wir einfach mal sehen
wie sich das weiter entwickelt ob die
veranstalter jetzt schneller bezahlen
und sonst muss eben weiterhin druck
gemacht werden